very many we will try this again
don't you love coming to my live streams
aren't they like the most professional
thing you've ever seen I'm always eating
something and something always goes
wrong let me know but do you want me to
turn my annoying voice down or the game
up a Bluebird team what a team a
bluebird team
the celery French and Samar with the eye
contact
[Music]
cool the volumes good
[Music]
this marks the latest in a series of
disappearances dating back to 1994 when
the students ventured into the hi Tom to
be seen
yes Maria I am paying okay Amy good but
got my dougie I'm actually got my friend
this time I am using a controller it's
good to hear from you
you should be driving and on your phone
especially on country ladies that's so
stupid
- you're about missing key join stretch
good idea why wouldn't it be
I mention appalled know just where they
went
I'm almost there Oh call you later okay
so I'm going into a spooky word to look
for a boy my set is joining the search
so shouldn't that mean he's going with
other people
alibi I'll explain if you aren't eating
something and something didn't go wrong
I would be concerned it's just a staple
of the Eichmann extremes already isn't
it
welcome back did you miss me and staring
at your dog instead
yeah but he wouldn't I mean if I had a
dog I think I would be looking at my dog
all the time no work would get done you
guys would never see me all right dog
oh yeah so there's the cars for the
other people so I guess I just got here
late my name is Ellis yeah what's the
dog's name though that's the most
important thing my dog okay this is cute
can I make em ginger I want you to be a
ginger doggy wait I can't even bloody
see him like is he even changing okay
now yeah now he's changing no he looks
like an actual wolf I like this
that's not even ginger though is it
that's just Brown that's the cute one
but he looks like an actual wolf I give
a pink green blue yellow or white ishka
I'm gonna give him a green one what I
color should you be boy blue eye color
pink give you blue eyes oh wait if I
make you wait look back at me if I make
you white with blue eyes Oh who's a
handsome handsome Zoey
okay I'm making him white with blue eyes
hmm I can pet a dog
I can pet the dog and I do said I could
pick come here why my move I'm moving so
fast the sensitivity is crazy wait wait
dog wait I need to stop being so
sensitive okay here we go
hopefully that will be better
don't like I don't like it I don't like
it
it's a lot the sensitivity started
without us okay let's get moving
know it doggy barking this bloody car
you are I still think it's too sensitive
oops I'm just gonna put it right down
why would you do we can change it again
if she loves it so what do you RT would
that be out this one let's find this kid
it's been through enough already
oh so this is the boy that we're looking
for Anthony if you stop pissing your
pants every time someone mentions the
witch and decided to show up check the
trunk there's a walkie-talkie in that
for you I'm also leaving your fruit of
the kipper looking for oh ok so should
we get one okey talking I guess shut up
sorry Anthony first come first served
landing what Sam in the forest why
didn't he take this okay how do I crouch
I want to get on your level I want to be
on your level how do I do how do I pet
you how do I be a good dog owner I don't
know right come here
yeah what is this
my ass you just use a mouse because this
is hard
go holding on being
let's pick up
choosing the backpack well this is my
backpack don't you put X on it Oh
I have a belt sink
oh don't smash
[Music]
hey Jess looking good since she hasn't
aged a day since then kind of see it
your fortune something of IU is lost
fear not though I see that there's still
a chance to recover it though your time
is running thin you must act now burn
too forth without fear as Lady Luck
smiles upon those brave hearts place
trust in your friends as they will come
to your aid when most needed my advice
watch your step okay yeah I am using
okay I have a photo oh yeah so this is
the boy I have a figurine this is
actually a figurine oh this reminds me I
stumbled across this amazing Instagram
profile and it was an illustrator and
they had a they've done these
illustrations of a wood carving while a
woodsman with a wood chopper
and he obviously had like lost his wife
or something so all of this like he did
little wood carvings of woman to remind
him of his like lost wife it was so cute
because he would carve woman out of
trees and then hug them but anyway
that's a different story
so now I didn't put this back to him
don't know maybe about there
okay this feels better
tomorrow
follow it his name's bullet nose cute
me and my boo
thank you only point each one to one
[Music]
point which reminds me I saw the cutest
little little pink pig cuddly toys today
on my lunch break at work but how do I
pet you what are you doing silly oh he's
so cute teeny they do still a knife at
you though it's call landing uh okay
[Music]
Tunnel - this is channel 2
Ellis today's to copy how do you know
did you know the channel joining the
search party sir we're to help
it's all there is to it bullets Wiggly
if he catches the scent they lead us
straight to the Bennett malate sir I'm
not gonna screw this up not this time oh
well sir
today used to be like a ranger or
policeman booth Roger that over now well
time to get to work
we got this ballot let's go come on Bali
Bali
this is Fallot yo right-hand dog listen
to his barking watch his body language
he'll be the first to alarm you have any
trouble but he'll need your help to deal
with it remember the way you treat him
can affect his behavior later in the
game that's cool okay well we'll be nice
to Bala stay close to him belongs
loneliness can affect your mental state
on cue paper uno if you lose sign up on
it press C to call him back
what is nearby look at him and hold C to
toggle oh here we go this is how we do
it is this how we make friends without
dog I don't want to oh I can't choose
yeah I have to do what the game tells me
to do you know buddy come on off you go
I'll pet you later
cool what'd you find you're looking for
you know not the search party buddy
where are you uh good week we communit
Barnett come here okay this is where we
know I'm not gonna reprimand him
oh I pet him good boy he's a good boy
he's a good boy
you know they already went through there
hey what we don't wanna stick then stay
close to meet you
what's not my friend why am i calling
just say I call I just caught her and
she didn't pick up why should playing
games of me hey Jess I got your message
wait I do yeah not much luck so far
but hey yeah at least bullets happy
we're out of the house Jess I'm sorry
about earlier you know how important the
system
yeah thanks Jess water will do a lie a
lie what what's up would you find the
world's negative goddamn trash King
coffee cup
oh that's nice of him he's picking it up
so you can put it in the bin later now
wish you were always the seeker to take
a bath sure let's go this way but I cute
boy was it once you find well I guess
you consider her to clean some case it's
not ours
when to a handsome boy that's what I
said mm-hmm
he's so [ __ ] little cutie okay what do
we have here
where are you going
are you sniffing Wow
oh okay okay this doesn't it related
never know little camping area few
friends came and slept all this
disgusting mattress oh hell you're not
surprised you brought oh thank you for
this is the working bags loans is in
love okay so they were here before it's
the police say hello yes what do you
what do you want
nothing a alright then stay with me am I
going the right way guys I don't know ah
there's police tape so I think so I just
feel like I've just gone back on myself
but there are lots of different pathways
just like in the real forest okay it's
more police tape opens getting a bit out
of breath we've already searched this
area
Oh No
where do I go not still ready how can
that be lost already are you going
yeah didn't I just go up here
I'm just following the path now dude do
we come in this way I hope we didn't
can we climb up these rocks
mmm all right dog tell me tell me your
secrets but go and search for something
show me the wonderful seek
nothing there huh what it
hmm well apparently you guys said bullet
will find something eventually so I'm
just gonna put all my hopes and bullets
basket was this twigs spooky even this
forest isn't that space whirring hello
oh they were gone sir
nothing a mmm
you know you're going the right way when
stuff starts jumping out here okay
thanks Alex I'm so excited I'm just
gonna follow the light I was quite
pretty isn't it
light rays
yeah I feel like if I follow the light
see Oh show me show me
nothing there huh nope
hello yes there you are where you find
something that's kind of creepy it says
Alexandra the person we're looking for
is in court Alexandra but what is that
can't tell if it's a head I think it's
someone's back
well nice one boy then we'll go back
this way we're on to something here uh
and yes before you ask I have watched
Blair Witch but it was a long time ago
hello hey what feel like you have
something to show me let's go on how
long am i streaming today probably not
too long to be fair to there's a weekday
but we'll see nothing
the [ __ ]
why are you crowding out you stupid I
mean you you lovely lovely does where
are you what were you just yelling at
yes
this is something up that oh oh that's
cigarettes I don't think you should be
getting into that kind of habit
it was that I can see something shiny up
here my nose is itching that will find
anything there yeah nice try having the
other way it was this it was the leaf
okay
and I didn't around here search
right a crossroads you got nothing okay
wait I've been here before
what do I do now
no no they already went through there
not this way okay very adamant for me
not to go that way not this way then
wait
yes not that when he said
I've already been around here what am i
doing
we round the circles alright show me the
way
where are you see if you can find
something buddy
bullets damaged
okay let me see it's the boys ha
beautiful now's not the time
Baltimore close this Peters going good
boy
what we need to hurry can you follow the
scent yes follow the scent
yeah boy see if you can find it
go get mr. bass I found Peters cat nope
I'm not gonna dig it out bullets at the
center I'm not risking and losing it
I'll keep you posted over now all right
go on keep going right behind you good
boss Oh God
dance
okay now we're in the spooky bridge
where's that duck
Oh dead end why am i why is my heart
beating
[Music]
[Music]
calm down us everything's fine it's on
your head
where are you
Hispanic and spamming c-span humming
Oh bless him this is actually a adorable
if you decided to show up don't leave me
like this okay buddy just be Ilona
find something oh yeah one two man is
true yeah yeah you know buddy
Oh
pick up this fan hey hey hey Jess no
Kingston here bye wait
Alice what's not to like that she just
worried about you listen I think I saw
something I gotta go
you guys ever been out in the forest
when it's dark on your own it's actually
terrifying but I've never had a whistle
like that I remember once I went for a
run in the woods and uh what the wood
went down the Sun went down and I had to
run back with my friend flashlight
oh wow is that tree oh right [ __ ] at
the tree
uh hello boy
Oh what's this ah camcorder
let's pick it up night Maria thank you
for coming
hello
yes maybe you should no I'm fine I'll
deal with it I just need a little more
time Ellis what you need is help
because meanest
unless I can't do this anymore what what
is it this time what I wasn't smiling
enough didn't say I love you for five
[ __ ] minutes Jesus Christ
Ellis do you even hear yourself yeah I
could hear myself just fine and I can
see the way you look at me like I'm a
[ __ ] loser the sick little puppy for
you to look after my yeah there it is
there it is
[Music]
I hope you
I tried to help you but
I just can't be around you anymore go
ahead get out leave me the [ __ ] alone
what happened
[Music]
Oh cry do you man
[Music]
this
Jeeter better yeah I want to introduce
you to several bullet meet you a new
partner he's been through a lot just
like you what certainly can
well you got something else going on
yeah yes he's the wrong color though was
that jazz
yeah I pass out in the 10:1 yeah
like a farmers
hmm looks charged yep that's zero
were you barking up coming that back
here mm-hmm
was it deep inside might as well see
what's on it
the red tapes allow you to manipulate
reality pay attention to the environment
and other lips both around you and in
the video fast forward and rewind to
stop the video in the key moments has
changed as states of positions that's
pretty cool
[Music]
okay so I can do W and ask to change but
I don't have any others I guess it's
around here somewhere maybe like yeah
what that bad
oh this is so weird
the car is actually it's oh this is
weird
okaycome how do I get to health this
wasn't here a minute ago
misty yeah it did
we'll get it together else
it's probably Peters be both to catch a
scent huh palette
[Music]
you know what to do buddy just like in
training good boy yeah you do great on
the force you brought some stubborn all
right oh wait what's all this well it
wait here wait up
it's damaged but relatively new probably
not something a nine-year-old could set
up okay let's go all right come on then
[Music]
look at that swagger what's going on boy
what excuse me hello what what is what
oh wait huh excuse me what am i doing
destroy it's gone oh okay we found
Alexandra and Olga is this supposed to
be happening I am moving without without
actually moving weird little bug that I
found
foresters are crazy you can see how so
much random folklore was written about
forests and creatures in the forest oh
my god dog don't do this what what we
want
hold up
still on track buddy get back I'm right
behind you I'm glad I got him this green
color let's pick up maybe go ahead we
went down a ravine and headed north to
an old campsite well you didn't find
Peters cap either listen you're still on
the trail keep moving north Emmett just
find the campsite and head north I'll
look for a landmark some in the right
direction posted over now
as little noises to my left
wait come here come on let's just have a
move Sookie mm-hmm okay I'll get
what is this why have you taking me
matter buddy that's another thing don't
worry I got this
[Music]
was his name Arthur says Alexandra Olga
Arthur I guess he's up maybe all the
people that went missing in the forest
perhaps oh oh oh don't why you coming
back bigotry yeah
okay pallet you go first it's not that
I'm a coward it's just it's just that I
like to let you leech
it's the same eyes as what he was
singing in his classic rumination just a
tree this is the tree just this reaches
the tree your hug hug the dog bubble hug
the dog hunt the dog good boy
no look is beautiful eyes this is bounce
color that's cute
okay let's go just the tree just the
treat is the truth
wait is this what is this cement excuse
me one where are we yeah actually you
know if anyone's ever done any
construction we reinforced concrete
foundations where's my dog
uh-oh excuse me oh that's terrible
yeah bullet oh god don't do that to me
again
Oh candy wrapper really come on would
you believe better than that oh maybe it
was the boys she did go find something
else should we not go down in that
little pit thing I guess we just have to
follow where the dog is mm-hmm there's a
car here Oh what is it what what wait
wait
now what I've expecting the middle of
the forest then again I wouldn't expect
me enforce concrete either hey you huh
what again oh you got any cut that means
nothing
thank you see maybe there will be like
artificial lights in here I knew it
it's Peter
right time to get time to get that bull
Ellis debase Peter didn't run away he
was kidnapped I found a tape it shows
the man who did it things appear he
sounds the gritty right now you don't
have much choice look this way just
gonna go by this way if you catch up
over now
yeah I'm kind of an idiot but you know
I'm so sorry
come on boy
let me go back
where's the pole but he just shot around
here that's not it
but come here boy come on boy
Peter's in danger and we're the only
ones who can help
damn are you sure pretty sure he would
have gone down there though but whatever
now uh-huh what
he doesn't unpracticed to Chechnya yeah
cuz I thought he would have gone down
underground are we walking in circles
boys yeah look give it to me
he's under us the boys underneath us I
think and that's what's happened father
bullet bullet bullet bullet bullet
bullet yeah come on boy don't make me
chase you normally mmm you are they are
they are don't leave me
okay pay attention to bullets behavior
his growling well I'm your danger
lurking the time during a fight keep him
close he'll help you locate enemies but
if left alone all becomes removal yeah
we can't let anything happen to our
little dogie dog good shout Tom let's
check out the M words let's check out
the um did the doctor sneeze the
JustGiving page so we fresh we have four
supporters thank you so much we've
already raised 47 pounds and 68 P thank
you thank you thank you
I already appreciate that I mean one of
those supports is me but wait let's have
a look and see who it is thank you Tom
save the Wombats thank you Michael cuz
Costanzo for great cause and thank you
PFD do I know who that is
hi miner her life thank you thank you
thank you that's cute okay yep cool it's
nice it's nice feedback um [ __ ] what did
I just do okay I just got the spinning
wheel I should not change things okay go
back to normal please
help what are you doing
no okay thank God thank God we're back
we're okay everything's okay
and back to the game
where is he
was a boy where's the boy
there you are thank God for this green
mmm
yeah I'm convinced about where we are
now
oh okay so I think I need to slow it
down or pause it when is on the light -
you know honestly wish this is it
okay well it's good to know that staying
in the light keeps you safe but I mean
that's kind of just a given with horror
games in general where do we want the
light to be so will this give us light
and random different places maybe don't
yeah well what you want
I don't think I'm ever gonna reprimand
this dog
I don't need only dummy dummy no no no
no
oh my god oh my god
hi okay I get I get the light it's very
simple divorce but like where the [ __ ]
is it coming from
oh my god stressed out no where are you
yeah yeah I actually I thought I was
gonna die
Oh
what is the point
why did you go even bullet come here now
you ask me it seems to me you're somehow
what it looks like every other tree you
what excuse me
which tree there's so many of them what
are you talking about
okay palate weights again come here boy
bullet oh wait what you need by but I
cannot see you they are no no no no
reneik want to give a cuddle
wave I've been here before
but oh it's this shut creepy tree again
why is it versus black stuff
is this
what is happening here
come here boy bullet why is he not he's
not barking come here where are you
oh come on stay you are right stay here
let me give you cuddles I think we need
it huh wait why are you going down that
I think we're going the other way
bullet we've already been here why are
we here again I thought we're going
underground now you know why not both
seek
barley Bella Bella again not again not
again not again where are you Hey oh my
god you right there
oh don't like this ballast bullet bullet
bullet yeah it's close
oh wait he's slow that's the way good
good good right in the bushes why are we
just going in the ground I don't
understand well a young man has
potentially become more wimpy what is
because I'm not as experienced anymore I
played our game in a while
[Music]
the lead they were cool okay now you may
go
ballot how they now you may go
this is like an overly protective parent
bullets you taking me around in circles
but it stop this right okay bullet oh
come here
okay now I am choosing where we go okay
isn't it close to me you're gonna follow
me this time okay boy good boy good boy
good boy
okay boy remember what I said you see a
close okay boy
wait no no what do you mean wait I want
him to come down here vodka find out
all right what do we do then
yes we got a bunch of photos got a paper
cup and they'll suck candy right
oh oh what is happened thank you for
following me
Eddard Eddard Edirne don't love life
hell yes doc love life
bullets
he'll bullet how Y is t3 on the circles
actually annoying to me boy deal I sniff
I know actually I think he's taking me
so my name aren't you a handsome boy
hablo español ah I don't understand
Spanish I know how to say you're
beautiful
tu eres bonito or Bonita right
I think palette where are you taking me
[Music]
you're such a little team yeah my god
there you are there you are okay we can
out in the clearing now
why is music acquit are we are we
actually going inside words he'll yeah
funny you actually take me in circles
boy
dude what the howdy he actually is right
you need to stop this
okay Jimmy what do I do
you come here
you stay stay
ok with you buddy bye this ominous tree
I got figure out what to do now we need
to refer to things for persons but it's
a grapple grapple ah good to know thank
you I could say something is beautiful
ok so obviously like the flowers are
beautiful but II don't believe that cute
good to know
um anyway I'm saying oh yes right let's
have a look at our inventory so I have
maybe I have
nothing's anything here that I can
actually pause on that will help me
[Music]
hmm
do we still have okay we still have the
baseball maybe I'll get out of it pretty
damn it I mean they were just given a
snack
you good well what are these buddy
Gidney good wait no come here
Boyd come here um okay Sikh
he's just taking me around the circle's
I honestly don't know what I'm supposed
to be doing
give me
Barry pull my sink search
what'd you find
he'll
oh and whenever we come in here it's
never it's fun so why'd you keep making
me come in here seek find something good
please please
he'll
- Mikey just randomly tell opposing cuz
I feel like I do horse here look around
you think I actually I'm teleporting I'm
very confused
he'll search
look
but
right
yeah maskings I'm asking it to find
something skelter no yeah we just keep
we've already been here before seek
Oh Montez donated hell yeah I'll
double-check in a second thank you
though
and thanks Tom for keeping me up to date
on this but wait stay wait wait well I
collect my uh my thoughts I mean
everything we've been taught is just to
follow the dog basically what we have in
here so you've already gotten everything
out of the Hat the toy car what about
this Field Manual do you want to sniff
this no put it back then I don't want to
know
you've got everything out there did you
get everything out of the toy car he's
not gonna find anything new what about
the Hat I've already given him this
already got everything you cut out of it
let's see oh yes it was only the red top
ones that you yeah what about things do
you want a sniffing hmmm what about this
you want a sniff this wasting time what
about this one
nothing on this one you wanna sniff the
candy this one is clean
or wasting time you're a sniff this all
sucks hmm
I'm at a loss
Andy what if I try my phone your signal
great boy can play games what you play
what's a super rugs super rags is a
doggy game thanks for following Admiral
Bashara
wait is that ash wait oh crap
my dog died okay so good so cute how
Messer wait am i trying it oh I'm trying
to get the little put-put-put mind if we
die now for a monster and we're just
like playing games on our phone Oh balls
I got 495 high school it's pretty bad
isn't it
what about Koba masters ya snake I
remember when I was a kid I used to
borrow my grandma's phone to play snake
on it and to be fat kids do that now
don't they they're like whenever I see a
kid that well maybe not so much anymore
they're like oh do you have Pokemon go
on your phone thank you for following
[Music]
Trey's oh yeah yeah so bad
ah don't forget to donate to charity for
the Australian wildfires porfavor oh
thank you very much
so this is the best dream you've ever
seen right I'm a sneak master
I'd never played slithery Oh though wait
how is that a lie it might be alive
okay right I'll song um okay so that's
games setting I can't have boys oh okay
that's changed too theme ooh what's this
thank you Matt Reeves production for
your fire that Tom do think I can make
it a cat or a plane or a car or people
or dog dog puppies okay I've got a
puppies theme I don't I don't know what
that's changed though ringtone Cyclops
can I ain't not yeah I'm gonna have sick
Cyclops brightness ah thank you Tom for
sharing the link for the charity it's
for the Australian welfare Oh God so
things really fund yes one okay cool so
that's my phone uh what else can we do
maybe you should try the walkie-talkie
what if we try
I thought the base a different channel I
mean I just wanted to say
[Music]
[Applause]
cap you're still in one piece and hey at
least we still got radio contact all at
all Morris yeah yeah you're right
Dixon overnight good friends but yeah so
what if we try the radio but we change
the channel anyone hear me
[Music]
this is the set sponsor okay are they
still here then wait am i that guy am i
that guy who's that guy
okay go search
cuz I don't know what else to do
oh wait I think he's going somewhere
house yeah are you taking me on a wild
goose chase why we go around in circles
okay this is not she infuriating because
I have no idea
just keep going back to this bloody tree
and at this tree
yep
hmm wait it's blood on that
there's nothing I can do on the tree
bullets
c'mere boy
so was that red demon thing that
attacked area the which maybe tape
equals or more than tree I think you
mean tape at the tree me was this tree
in that tape wait
bullet mallet boy boom I'm back come
back to me boy
bullet should i rep remand him maybe oh
[ __ ]
no I'm just gonna ask him to stay wait
here buddy
what was that what just happened oh
thank you so much for the super chat
wait who was that
can I see Christina I already appreciate
it what did you say um let's get the
YouTube chat gosh darn it whoa where is
super super chef super Jeff where is
which are super super chair uses said
how's it going well then it'll oh wait
wait did you say that law it's not just
the new super chef thing I am very
confused oh yeah because they told me
they had some like weird emoji thing so
you must have chosen that I'm no chief I
sound like an old lady thank you
it's going good I'm just a bit confused
about what to do in the game now but I
appreciate that super chat thank you
very much falling tree in the tape oh
okay thank you for the heads up guys we
we should now carry on
right oh yeah you're already saying good
good yeah you stay that and now let's go
to the tape
Oh with your night vision
can i how do i watch tapes here
that's a breadcrumb trail I don't one
that one dangers okay apparently there
was a falling tree or something I'll
look out for this tree what trees have
you got here
do we is any of this look similar
there's no fallen tree
what did you mean a different one more
oh dude that fallen tree
okay cool
all right doggie I know where to go this
time you
[Music]
stay close board I think it's back this
way
now have you heard about this Darwin
emoji pain shut up ah thank you so much
for the tip Nicholas Frank then wait
what the hell that's a that's a ma be
sure thank you I know it's a fool quite
I appreciate the thank you thank you
thank you I will do more I promise I
will be live streaming more uh here we
go right okay so now I was this tree
wait what was its water coming from
dude what
Oh new things thank you for your help
guys okay come here come here
I'm on the wrong Channel how are you
talking to me is that by the
construction it's on my way here I could
get there in a few minutes
stay where you are okay I'm gonna go
back the plot thickens
let's go let's go back bye
I'm gonna Pat you
when to a handsome boy
the handsomest
and stay close stay close to me okay
stay close
I can't move which way I went Oh balls
and I lost so there was somewhere around
here ah
[Music]
can you help me can you help me please
okay seek I think I'm lost
please try and find that tree again we
did nothing there are no okay then I'll
just keep trying oh I have a text I
thought I had them signal you don't have
a signal
unless it look higher between the leaves
excuse me
cool thanks but the jump-scare ah how
are you from question marks I'm good how
are you good Jesus okay look high up
between the tree between the leaves do
you mean higher is in high or higher as
in oh my god I don't like it I need to
go make some food see what the hell okay
ah
we're being watched we are being watched
how did they get our number what what
kind of freaks have I've been given my
knowledge all right let's go
oh where am I going oh why why am i got
bad memory oh oh I didn't mean to go
that way how did they turn around I did
a full 180 they did not mean to do this
when you go back down this way oh this
game I'm pretty sure though that's its
intention is to make you you're very
lost
ah cuz it's definitely the way that I
came right oh my gosh
have they done this on purpose is it box
up now can i oh here we go
wait is it okay okay I think I found it
oh boy here we go
hey don't talk to me like I'm crazy
screw you in it I don't need your help
it's you who needs me I'm the only
person in forest who's even remotely
close to finding that kid
and you there
damnit
Oh oh no don't do jujitsu okay okay okay
I'm ready I'm ready come from ready
Oh balls okay okay okay okay
where did you get
haven't seen the game yet why did I save
the blood game oh my god oh thank god
okay well where is he where's my doll
Oh scheisse where's the dog where's the
dog where's the bloody other ways
oh I'm just looking at the dogs looking
at so I'm supposed to be doing in it
which way
kill
I'll kill you with my light ah Thank You
Ross well please protect palette I will
protect I will protect I will protect my
little dog without it he's a he's a good
boy I mean to be fat Louie I think I
think a car were to be pretty good in
this situation as well anyway I've got a
text I'm gonna read my text and then I'm
probably gonna go soon health 101 moving
is always bad and standing those who
don't move have 9 to 9 percent higher
chance of dying better start walking
what if I ask you what if I just stay
here will they actually kill me
should I call their bluff
kind of want to you just stay here you
know what wait
let's save and then we'll stay here for
a little bit
we'll just stay here for a little bit
because we will look at who has been
giving to charity
we have when you support us and I
already knew her that is good Tom told
me it's montage given ten pounds one
petting session two bullet for every
pound oh damn
okay that's ten petting sessions
let's get this going then
start petting
start the pets away there
oh gee one your Uttara man wait one
second I'm just going to give you the
link to the Just Giving page there you
go that's the link to the Just Giving
page oh yeah right
ten pets okay one
yeah good dog
what if we die while paying him because
we like stay in the same place for too
long I think they're bluffing Oh
- handsome boy what we've done man task
we've done so many so many licks three
Montes wants this good dog
now we get to see all the animations in
their glory oh we haven't seen that one
yet
hmm wait come back
Montez model is five what you ahead
support yeah we've seen them acquire
features I love how his eyes just glowed
good boy oh my god thank you so much for
the tip Nick thank you thank you thank
you tell you what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
I'm gonna give like most of this to the
charity as well I've already donated
I'll do again uh how many is that
seven six seven
eight I hope you are we're here Amanda
it's what if he's not even here so he
was seeing all these pets nine
where do we go now good boy no no no no
that's basically the theme song to this
game yeah because that's all I'm saying
the whole inside side ok last pass good
and then I'll let you don't let you
leave ok good boy he's watching yeah
yeah
okay now see cute with rubble find
something new for us
oh good
anything here not today ah okay well I'm
guessing we go we go back to that broken
bridge
mm-hmm yeah belly is one of the best
boys here he's me is the cutie cutie pie
there's nothing to do here okay I'm
gonna ask you to have a little look
around and see what you can find to seek
you find anything Bernie why did we pick
up this tree then what if we make it
foam now
that's so cool the longest hike well I
got an achievement not sure why but I
did
what about now can you find anything
like : on the tree maybe wait pass me
anything on the tree that does foul
bless you
sneezing
okay so I need to get this back up so I
can walk back up again
and what about the other tapes I mean I
don't think the clue is anything to do
with us now
okay please back up
no I
tell you what dog should we just like
try and go back down to the cellar thing
I don't really know I'm taking it's true
are they are cheek
nothing a
hey Nick yeah so for the patreon letters
I send them all around for Christmas
I sent I sent top tears a poem so if any
of you were those that got that let me
know because I gave I gave you a little
poems that I've made into little like
things that you could have no portraits
so hopefully they were good tonight the
first time I've done anything like that
before on see the little Christmas
present for you guys um nothing there
bull might just come with me I'm gonna
try and find where we go now
[Music]
I am lost in the woods
ooh there's a creepy tree
okay let's go down here
who the kid in just run away
okay I'm gonna try going down here again
stay here boy no
yeah not clean so you could find
something buddy would you like a folk
music yeah I like it good I like a good
mixture nothing gotta say though I I
will always have a soft spot for my old
humor me sick I really don't know I
don't know guys I think I'm gonna have
to go because I'm honestly at a loss and
I need to make some no easy boy easy
okay just just come this way come on
we've gotta go gotta go we're gonna go
wait is it one of those stupid things
again Rosa I can't even see it
I can hear it as where we see what is it
this is actually annoying me now I'll
hear it it's gone
that's Matt I yeah ah there you are so
you I'll give you a little pat now yeah
good dog
no cute
let's go just stay with me please
stay close to me stick with me
didn't he find anything actually Oh see
hey that's some stuff in these woods
nothing there huh there are some stuff
in these here woods yeah
wouldn't be cool if we ran into a fox or
like some deer we can make our own
little animal clan and then we wouldn't
have to be scared anymore
why am i back here ah this is the wrong
way I need to get forwards not backwards
not in circles
all right dog oh did we find a path I'm
just gonna keep going forward
ah nope nope nope nope but there is a
path here ooh dog dog dog dog boy
look can you come in here oh yeah
ah wait isn't it oh wait maybe I haven't
been you
oh I happened here before oh my gosh I'm
so curvy Minich
I know you're there I just found your
car come on talk to me
right so if we go back to the tree book
yes should be them a lot hmm say save
the right channel three say the lights
okay should we go on to child three and
then say light
the night the light nice I can write
that lies white who is this hello
why the hell not
yeah go on then listen to the Christian
man mm-hmm
it's Keith good job buddy yeah good jump
in deep wait wait come here come here
come here come here come in stay I have
something for you seeing as you're a
very good boy
I will give you little snack being a
good boy
oh wait what's a ball yeah big good put
thank you for finding the Keith
joy is in this side punk my doing such
an eejit so carefully
why do I let the doc come in with me
poor dog another missing person
officer Wilson was notified of the
disappearance of Todd McKinnon by Adam
Braun according to his testimony
McKinnon was surprising him with timber
but he suddenly stopped about two weeks
ago Brown was unable to establish any
form of contact with McKinnon the
initial search yielded no results and
the containment could not have been
founded it had been found in his hands
McKinnon has no history of mental health
problems currently examined hypothesis
deliberate disappearance deliberate
disappearance by someone else over him I
guess by him McKinnon's neighbors claim
that he was frequently visiting the
defunct sawmill of tapping discrete
timber company in the Black Forest Hills
McKinnon is gone missing oh okay wait so
either either McKinnon is gonna be the
guy it's okay I'll come back to you in a
second um McKinnon is gonna be the guy
on the radio like helping us maybe he'll
be our friend but he's like in another
dimension or something it's obviously
something weird happening with
dimensions or something like that yes um
but maybe there's a twist at the end it
turns out that he's the one that could
kidnap a little boy or maybe if there's
like kind of like damage in the time
loopy thing going on maybe he's the boy
when the boys older and he never escaped
and now he's helping others don't know
hypothesis maybe theories okay
[Music]
the fuse panel is located under the
steering wheel to identify parents
important please check the following
okay whoa whoa we'll have a look at this
let's have a look into the steering
wheel man oh oh put the keys on
oh no battery I just take a look under
maja no battery what did you think was
no battery uh I think he was about to
say he should take a look under the hood
okay dip boy thank you for waiting so
patiently yeah yeah good dog
stay close bullets
awesome Oh shite alright that didn't why
did I do that
we don't maybe to hear the radio
oh wait
what movie is it okay
listen to that no one listens there's
some cool music oh god not bad
okay this'll be right cool wait I don't
want to I'm gonna have a look at the UM
I can't read it okay what much what I do
[Music]
from life
front light 20 amp 120 amp nine and
seven what's six cigar lighter lights
already need that lunch good birdie
oh wow oh my god it's daytime I'm so
slow cool well this is good you know
it's less scary now dogs okay I have
moved I have absolutely moved location
bulla buddy
now I'm really losing it this time our
night oh yeah good dog comes we don't
pull it by Nick may or may not be awake
have a good day where oh that's already
lovely to hear thank you I'll be doing
more streams day you are don't you worry
okay buddy can you find anything
nothing a
I will actually leave soon I did this
every single time history I'm gonna
leave in five minutes if something
happens
oh I love okay I'm getting a lot of text
messages puppets call me when you can
anyway I was just trying to it just
going to ha I don't know why I've been
thinking about us a lot like yeah no
it's just okay there's a message you're
avoiding me you're still running around
the woods hey I keep getting bumped to
your voicemail okay I think we need to
call Jess isn't it a bit early for you
you don't want to talk no no no it's
it's good to hear your voice
listen I'm sorry about before
Suze all I do is apologize and then I
say something stupid
it's like we're trapped in a cycle of
[ __ ] he just walked through that
long I saw Matt hey as long as we're
getting paid we were good for a while
so what happened
what happened yeah
loving more than yours
are you doing we do remember yeah yeah
why did weird music did I miss something
guys
but stay stay stay guys freezing
bullet across the river for you come
here violent career I mean I try to say
to be fat cute
it's too cute of manner woman
you see what made you look at something
over here
yeah
would we go
thanks true love yes Remax is a very
charming
why why are you turning away from me are
you again good boy
if he is changing his actions due to how
I treat him I'm just wondering if he's
gonna get naughty because I'm just
praising him all the time
nothing there huh
okay um stay close to me then and I'll
go searching
what is it believe let me take a look
Jesus close the flood
not it's just but boy I don't understand
oh my gosh is our friend is a shower
friend Lainey oh god you know you
deserve better than this
you're the killer Oh skin this face
clean cuts
probably postmortem neck wound
deep
these headaches billion
lettings badge no one deserves it more
than Han
when he was tough experienced
he's holding one of those creepy photos
deafs like and that'sa no it's all the
backs of them who are they is it some
sort of cult or is it the people who
died here before oh my god where's my
dog where's my dog where's my dog
where's my dog was murder don't don't
don't don't don't
Oh God
Oh
it's how I died that's how we did it
[Music]
creepy so or anything that I could use
what were you doing here sure
this is no longer just a missing person
case come on boys
we gotta finish this peter auntie aleni
it's right I will be going very soon so
if you want to give to charity do it
sooner please is in the description of
the YouTube and you can probably find it
in the comment but I will give you the
link again soon gonna be on this one
what Bertie
don't want my dog to sniff it you sure
oh hey Jamie is it a red tape it is a
red to sheriff Emmitt living guy who
cared about everything and everyone
[Music]
beside I
a little down post easy
I can't even see this one peroxy corrupt
corrupted seeds
I haven't see that one
[Music]
bullet oh can you find anything in here
contravening article 52 of the NC
General Statutes publicly disrespects
ensures contempt for national symbols
our military service and the patriotic
soldiers he had once the honor of
serving with okay so probably find the
rest of its in my house ballot don't you
run away no
oh wow it's super foggy why you just
randomly sitting down
we're not a where to go
this
way back
was your client
and our makeup
Sego PTSD look
oh [ __ ]
we gonna
go round
cool
oh wow we're going into the biggest tree
wound
season no not now come on work
this is over you go yeah the camera is
so distorted oh this is cool
baby and baby yeah baby
I mean father but then once a being nope
nope nope nope nope nope
I'm going in circles oh my god father
every day - I had two guys sing
but this is great but this is not she's
really good game these people they love
me that's not a person what is that I
can't even tell what that is
well where are you
yeah thank you for donating I'll check
I'll check the Just Giving page in a
second
I can't even turn around I don't know
what to do bummer
well where are you booth
I am much they hardly confuse it but I'm
just kind of stay in here
I'm actually stuck Oh
going left to right left and right right
I see nothing myself out that
well it's what are you
just so you know won't let me run I
don't think that's ballot do you think
they'll get me if I stop moving do you
think I should turn around
nothing oh crap
Oh
uh hello oh no it's not gonna be like I
want it to be my girlfriend but I know
it's not gonna be I have one new voice
message
wait I need to go on my eccentric voice
mail
che che zur Chazy Chazy I don't think it
was supposed to spoil anything
oh wait I'm so much for calling for
brother
skulls beautiful lovely
wait it's gonna be like that girl she
call Jess I think she's gorgeous is she
gonna be here waiting for him off the
record Ellis what the hell happened you
responded to a robbery call when you got
there you saw them leaving the store you
took out your gun you told them to stop
the kid reached for something
was it a weapon no and then what well
you know what happened Adam chin Peters
brother I don't know what I was thinking
was the last person he'd want to see for
all I knew I could have tripled him for
life
yes that is something I had to do
rubberband ting
[Music]
[Music]
so is that the face of like a kid that
died because of him or someone that died
because of him
ah there you are your how did we end up
back here oh [ __ ] of the camp again
ah where is it
that little boy looks like someone left
it here for us it's him
sitting nearby let's find a buddy okay
we'll find it
oh yeah put down all that stone okay
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry okay I'll
get out I'll get it where is it ah here
it is
Marius I will not marry you again I'm
being stupid
time to leave ah it's the same a lot
older
this doesn't make any sense before we go
let's just pet I dog one more time and
then I'm gonna check the Just Giving
page and then I'm gonna go
she is food in soon
I am feeding now okay so I'm gonna save
as well
Chapter seven already now bad I don't
know how many how many chapters there
are but ah okay thank you so much for
watching I will make this big big big
[Applause]
yeah thank you so much for watching I'm
gonna just check out there just getting
paid and I will share the link with you
now if anyone wants to donate cuz you
can still donate
after this it's perfectly fine um but
yeah this was my first year of 2020 my
first stream in a house where I'm gonna
be staying for a lot longer so that's
gigs I'm now living with a friend she's
in that room so I don't quickly annoying
her it's 9 o'clock oh dear and yeah I
will be doing more of these so anyway
thank you so much I am actually planning
on doing another charity stream with
this Sunday with my friend Amy playing
we are here to get them oh I was here
together over there together something
like that um but yeah we're gonna play
that game together and that'll be for a
slightly different charity but still to
do with the wildfires because yeah
they're still going on and we still need
help so why not but anyway I just want
to say thank you so much to michael
tonic you said it's not much but i hope
it helps but 30 pounds i think it's a
lot like thank you very very much I
really appreciate it
so overall right now we have managed to
raise 87 pounds 68 pence for the
Australian works fire Relief Fund which
is pretty amazing it's always the
hundred pounds yes thank you so much for
your generosity and thank you all of you
who also did super chaps and and all the
other stuff I really appreciate it
it was a nice welcome back so cuz I
don't know why whenever I don't stream
for a long time I get kind of scared
just dream again
good that they might do it and it never
is it's just like seeing old friends
again Kevin stop being cheesy um anyway
yes this living situation is definitely
definitely definitely gonna see me your
Tara man thank you so make sure you can
still donate if you want to donate make
sure you follow me on Twitch that's
probably the best place to follow me on
Twitch but I mean on Twitter
you can't follow me on Twitch as well if
you want to but if you want to find out
what I'm doing kind of on the day then
follow me on Twitter it's probably the
best place to be if you want to see what
I'm up to you
Instagram is always a good one as well
and you get some visuals of what I'm
doing
and I like to update my story quite a
bit and expect some cool YouTube videos
soon and I'm working on on making
stories I've realized that like last
year I've realized those things that I
really want to do and there's stuff that
I want to start making and I'm
prioritizing that over just sharing I'm
I'm pirated in quality over quantity
basically and yeah I want to
I've always thought writing stories I've
always wanted to do narrative based
videos and things like that so it's
gonna take me a lot longer but at the
end of the day it's things that I will
trial proud to share so yeah a lot of
fun stuff coming on the YouTube channel
so oh good show mantas in the
description on YouTube there is a
discord channel a discourse service
right that you can all join if you are
patreon so you get your own your own
little channel which I am very active in
but I'm also active on there anyway so
let me just get a share for this one
I'll invite you guys